So then onto our brush settings, we have a few things at our disposal here.
We can have a circular brush like you saw in the example.
We also can alpha a brush where we can assign a texture, a texture sorry, just to a pattern or an alpha style stamp which we can then use to paint into the landscape.
So you don't just have to use a circle brush when editing landscapes.
We can select this alpha which will allow us to use a texture as a mask here.
And then also if we select a pattern, it will project a pattern onto the landscape which can be used as a mask.
So if we look at the settings here, both the alpha and pattern brush will allow you to adjust the look of the texture that is projected onto the landscape.
And then you can store the different masks in the RGB and the alpha channels of a 2D texture.
So if we use a clay brush to give the top of the brush a flatter look than the standard alpha brush, we can do that.
And here are some settings that you might want to use between an alpha and a pattern brush, for example.
And then there are several different types of brush fall offs that can be selected with these settings enabled.
So you can adjust the brush fall off to be more or less the brush fall off input in the brush settings section.
And you can adjust the brush fall off from point one to one essentially.
So we can see the smooth, the linear, the spherical, the tip.
And you can just see how the different settings may adjust to whatever your desired result is.
So that's the end of the video.
Thank you for watching.